[Music]
hello and welcome to another wolfram
tech talk i'm arben kalzichi and today
i'm joined by etienne bernard a former
physicist who worked here at wolfram
research as the lead of our machine
learning group for
seven years seven years i believe is
that right at the end something like
that yes yes give or take yeah all right
well why don't you tell us a little bit
about what you're doing now and this
machine learning book that you've
written yeah okay so
thank you hi evan um so yeah as you said
i worked at wolfram for for about eight
years
and um developing
machine learning tools match learning
applications
and uh and at some point i wanted to
kind of share the understanding that i
that i that i got from these years of
development
about machine learning and into a book
and so that's why i wrote this book
and uh and now i'm actually
transitioning
i'm still a little bit tired with with
wolfram research it's a soft transition
but but i'm trying to to
continue exploring um making machine
learning more accessible
so we we kind of did that at wolfram uh
absolutely i think i think we we pushed
what was possible but
there's still one last thing that it
requires you to know a programming
language
as i'm trying to explore you know how
far we can go without programming
language to allow people that cannot
code at all
to to
create machine learning applications as
well
so we'll see so i
i i i'm starting a company called new
mind
to work to work on that
and uh i guess today i'm going to talk
about book right
yeah please do i mean it certainly seems
like a challenging problem to help
people who don't know how to program
necessarily to develop machine learning
applications yeah yeah
you know there are a lot of super
functions and stuff in the wolfram
language to do with well to do with
machine learning that i personally have
used without knowing too much about kind
of
what's going on underneath the surface
necessarily that i found very useful so
curious to hear what you're working on
now on this front
yeah i mean it's it's still it's still
very early so so
uh we don't know yet how far we can push
i mean of course knowing a programming
language you know there's still things
that will be
only doable when you know programming
language of course you cannot replace
everything but but
my my bed is that we can maybe you know
80 90 of it
uh can be can be done but at that point
you know it's it's very early we're just
starting we're focusing on natural log
processing first
these are things that i think more
easier because it's kind of
same
thing same pre-processing
uh same same method and so on uh
to tackle more uh random application
that's gonna be more
challenging certainly
all right well you've written a book
here right
uh yep it kind of helps uh helps get us
started on this topic
so why don't you tell us a little bit
about this book and kind of what the
purpose of this book is and furthering
this goal you're talking about about
kind of making machine learning more
accessible
okay maybe i should share
and show you yeah
it's not the book yet
it is uh it's a notebook as you can see
that that's the type of book the type of
book yeah
that's how i developed this uh this uh
this book i mean that's how i wrote this
book and um
so yeah it's an introduction to machine
learning
um so so the the
there's kind of three goals in mind
uh one is to teach you what machine
learning is
um another one is to understand you know
what it does you know what kind of
applications you can solve with it
the second one is to teach you how to
apply machine learning yourself
and and the third one is to teach you
how it works
how it works underneath you know so a
little bit more academically this part
um but i think that even if you have
only one of this goal i think this this
book is already useful if you just want
to know what machine learning is
it's kind of separated these three goals
not to put complex things for people
that just want to know how it you know
what it is or or how to play a little
bit with it without caring about you
know how whatever method works
[Music]
and
i think one particularity of this book
is that it uses the word from language
um
and it's used it uses it in uh for
several purposes
one is of course you know to teach you
like how to do machining in one language
but it's not just that it's also to
teach you the concept of machine
learning using the wolfram language
so
right that seems like a good vehicle for
that because you know you can work at a
very high level like i was saying i i
worked with you know classify and
predict before and those things will you
know they work in a way that kind of
makes sense even if you haven't gone and
read a textbook about machine learning
already so it's a good way to start
definitely definitely most functions in
a wolf language are kind of
self-explanatory and very high level and
so it's it's uh it's a long way that is
closer to natural language than regular
programming language so so i think that
that makes sense uh to use it in a book
a bit like uh how is it called this
pseudocode but but yeah yeah
um pseudo code that is actual code
exactly exactly so actual code that you
can modify that you can run and and so
on play with
um
so you know typically that that's how it
goes it's like a text and a bit of
computations or a bit of code
text again code text code so that's the
function predict that you're mentioning
before
this is to explain how to predict a
numeric variable
and so on
that i think i work from we call this a
computational essay
uh alternative text and computation
text computation graphics visualizations
exactly whole shebang exactly exactly so
that's kind of um
uh how it is
and so this obviously we will show you
how to to do machine learning you know
using predict for example and
and how to plot you know to visualize
your model and things like that
um but then it's also about concepts so
if i if i look a regression measure so
we could look at the mean squared error
for example
and to
usually to teach mean square error you
put a formula like that
and it's very well suited for some
people that know formula very well
uh but some other don't like it so much
uh i mean this one is simple so but like
even myself as you mentioned i did
physics theoretical physics i hate big
formulas i don't know why
yeah and that's why we're in physics and
that's something else right we want to
try and keep things simple exactly
exactly and
so so the alternative is to actually
well let's let's compute the mean square
error from from scratch so first we make
predictions at the predictions then we
compare this prediction to the true
values that's residuals
we can show an instagram of the
residuals
and then we can square them and compute
them in and that's what the square
means square error is
so
i didn't went all the way and remove the
formula because i believe people
especially the ones that are suited for
formula is great to have it yes um so i
kind of do this double thing like um
computations and math and visualization
of course that i think everyone likes
visualization yeah i think i think
that's a really good way to do it
because you know this is
a little strange but i saw this thread
on twitter where it was
a computer scientist talking about how
you know
writing something like in python or
whatever it was they wrote you know
product
as you know this variable goes from here
to here of something and they were
saying this makes so much more sense
than this thing with like this weird
capital pi you know i understand there's
so much better than this crazy math
formula even though it's the same thing
and i you know yeah i hadn't really
considered before that people who might
not have you know taken that math if
they'd learned it from a computer
science perspective it's a lot easier to
do it that way for them than looking at
this formula yeah exactly exactly i
think it's
it's uh it's not yeah not everyone will
agree which one is better for them of
course
but i completely agree with you that
some people
so yeah that's kind of what it is and um
you know
i guess i could go in the content later
and each chapter has like some takeaways
some vocabulary
oh that's that's very useful to have a
vocabulary section i realized i didn't
really i mean i didn't realize that
before when doing the vocabulary section
i was like oh my god that's that's a lot
i think it's useful it's useful in
general but particularly with machine
learning when i've tried to learn about
it i found that there are just so many
different terms that you know they're
very close to something that i know
already but they're subtly different in
this context so having a list like this
is really fantastic
and uh and exercises of course
i think this is kind of uh necessary to
to consolidate whatever you saw in the
chapter
yeah
you can see these are some pretty you
know high level exercises for you know
just chapter four of an introductory
textbook right
like you know visualize because
it's on purpose actually i i always
dislike the precise decide about do this
do this dude
then you're kind of a machine that can
solve little problems but you never
managed to lose
yeah problems like that treat the treat
the user as a machine
yes exactly a lot better for you to sit
there and conceptualize about these
things i think it's it was great maybe
you know for for the teachers
because then they can you know it's not
just you succeed or you're fail you can
have intermediate thing and yeah guide
you a little bit but i think it's not
real life so they're kind of open-ended
as well
it's uh it's open and they exercise like
the goal is not for you to succeed like
the size
the goal is for you to play
with you know to try stuff to
to get a notebook
um you know try to run some stuff
try to have some success and and uh
that's really the goal uh make you
apply um
without necessarily getting the perfect
answer
and uh actually i didn't write answers
for the exercise and i don't think i
will
for this for this purpose
uh maybe if too many people ask me
um so i know maybe i could go in the
content
um i think a little bit of
things do you think are
most unique and important about this
text that you've written
so
okay i
should go there maybe maybe before just
to give you an overview
um so
the first two chapters i mean there's a
short introduction to the war from
language which is not enough for you to
know the wolf in language but you know
it's just a start then then
i think to
take better advantage of the book is
it's better to you know for example read
an elementary intellectual from long
great or something like that and you'll
enjoy the book more but you can also
with
just basic understanding uh continue
reading the book
right um
then there's two introductory chapters
so this is really
for the what machine learning is
and uh i think it's
very accessible i think everybody
everybody can read that and understand
you know it's a bunch of examples kind
of like
two main class of machine learning in my
opinion this the one that deals with
images text audio
which are sometimes called artificial
intelligence
um then there's some that are more about
you know tabular data sort of things you
find in companies that dynasty and this
work on yes it's really nice because you
have you know you have images i saw a
little audio snippet there
you've got text numbers you've got kind
of uh
i try to make it as i love images i try
to make it as
many pictures as possible
and
this explains the main paradigm so it's
also very introductory chapters what
supervised learning is what unsupervised
learning is clustering
animal detection
synthesizing the missing values these
sort of things
and then um there's
a few chapters classification regression
clustering which are really task
oriented lack the function of
mathematica actually
dimensionality reduction distribution
learning so you kind of this four five
main tasks
that are that are detailed so this is a
bit more about how to practice machine
learning yourself
um
and then including data processing yeah
and then there's uh chapter five which
is about how it works now the name says
maybe i should change it to how machine
learning works
i don't know i'm not an editor i can't
make that choice for you so eddie didn't
tell me that it was a problem but you
know now that you mentioned i will i
will run a you know poll
[Laughter]
um
and uh so yeah these ones are a little
bit like
i mean
the one about the tasks are very
example-oriented you know car versus
truck let's solve this problem
um i don't know titanic survival that's
a very classic classic right example
let's solve it let's do a bit of that
analysis blah blah blah visualization
let's look at the model we produced
our topic classification let's get
things from wikipedia
you know train a topic classifier
we'll analyze how it how it classifies
things
uh
and deploy actually there's deployment
here like how to deploy the
the model on the cloud for example
and so on image notification
and then this chapter is a little bit
more
a bit more academic a bit more academic
you know um
what is a model what is what are
non-parametric methods you know which
are basically
neighbors
i like putting that in the middle like
introduce people to some you know
specific applications and then say by
the way yeah this is what's going on and
i had
yeah
i had big uh mental fights about that
whether i put this chapter in the middle
or after all the tasks
and exactly what you said i said like if
i were reading this book i would be
happy to see classification regression
but i would be like how it works how
does it work
um
on the downside this chapter got bigger
than what it was supposed to be
it's supposed to be the sweet how it
works in the middle you know so
for the most curious and it kind of grew
a little bit and i wanted to put more
how it works after
which i did but
it grew a little bit so
i guess
if some people you know
uh
yeah a bit scared about that like they
could jump it and continue reading this
this this
this section and maybe come back later
yeah can read the pieces that they're
interested in maybe
yeah if they want to just get to the
get to the meat of it get back to the
meat of it i guess
exactly
and and then it goes deeper into how it
works here which is you know the classic
supervised learning methods so
you know you don't really need that to
practice machine learning
with with good automated tools but you
know maybe your use and it will make you
a better practitioner if you know that
you know
kind of to be the expert practitioner is
good to know this this method so
explains what you know decision tree for
example it's very classic classic thing
what what would be nice to show gaussian
process maybe watching process
you know it does is nice
uh that models uncertainty pretty well
actually this one goes a little bit
deeper into really hard question process
works i don't want to scare anyone this
is like the this is the hardest part of
the book that explains actually how
question process works that is about
you know
uh question processes random functions
and conditions functional data so this
is like
you don't necessarily need to read that
or understand that to practice
yeah but it's there if you need it
yeah
i
end up making it a little bit more
complete that
that that was intended the beginning um
uh but i don't think anybody will be
unhappy about that yeah um
oh yeah and these important chapters uh
deep learning methods
was probably the biggest chapter
actually that's also
i didn't realize but after doing it i
mean of course deep learning is a lot of
things to say
and it ended up being a chapter it was
like the size of three or four chapters
but
you can just sneak that in at the end
there nobody
exactly so it's it's a full-on
introduction to to neural networks
uh you know going from explaining
artificial neurons
um
to
classic neural networks
um
and then explaining
how they learn so you know
um
you know grand descent for example oh
yeah yeah yeah uh so yeah i went i went
a bit bit down the rapid all but
it's a good rabbit hole to go down it's
a good review i think it's yeah i think
many would be interested
and uh this is also an example of the
computational essay actually
uh because to teach grand descent well
let's do it let's let's take a function
that's that function we can visualize it
and then
and then we can compute the gradient
and
and then we can do one step
of grand descent
you also have the formula if you want
but you know you have the code after
uh and that's one step to you know to
find the minimum
local minimum in that case i think it's
gonna go there
um
of this uh of this function
and then and then you can do it several
times and kind of this trajectory so
yeah really instructive you know
yeah so for those who don't know uh yeah
it's it's optimization method classic
optimization method grand descent
so
yeah this sort of thing explaining i
don't know by propagation
um
how you compute uh the gradient in your
network
yeah so anything anybody might be
interested in with regards to deep
learning here is kind of
yeah
it's also more complete than i entered
in the beginning but
uh and then it goes like
particular architectures uh
convolutional networks like let's see
2d convolutions that's that's that's
operation that are in this network is
network used for computer vision to
recognize what is in what what are in
images like the object in images for
example
so you kind of explain what was what is
the convolution
procedure
and
yeah um
actually one neat thing because you ask
is there some neat thing you want to
show
yes uh
i went down it's not there actually
where is it where is it modular image
classifier yeah classifier
i went down the rabbit hole to explain
uh try to understand what this uh
neural network we're doing
so this is a kind of a classic method
it's like feature visualization
and basically you ask
you ask a network
what are the
the the the input
that activates the most a given part of
the network
so it's an optimization process you move
the input
to try to make a given part of the
network activate
and and what's nice is that when this
part of the network is low in the
network
it's in the beginning of the network
then you see these kind of simple shapes
the simple
patterns let's say which mean that this
part of the network is kind of
understanding simple things like edges
and objects
and then if you ask a little bit higher
you will see more complex patterns so
it's it's understanding more complex
structures
and then even
um and at the end you kind of see or not
not exact object but yeah you cannot
understand i don't know it seems like
it's like building up these kind of uh
deep dream-esque images it's yeah it's
very close it's very close uh to to the
deep dream thing so a lot of fun
generating these images
um yeah those are really nice yeah
anyway just uh
i think that's all right but
yeah that's that's uh that's pretty
fantastic
all right well when can folks uh get
their hands on this book or notebook as
it were
hopefully in about uh a month
that's pretty soon we are we on the
final stages
uh
yeah kind of let's let me close that but
yeah finish the last the last edits
uh
now it's the cover that's that's the
current cover you saw
which i think i think is pretty close to
the final one i like it
and yeah they they should be
at some point we'll put online version
as well and so you can have access to to
all the all the code
uh
because sometimes the code is hidden
that's something i didn't yeah i saw
some iconized there yeah yeah it's not i
think in a book you know there's like
like the options let's say okay that's
the options for the visualization of
this histogram like nobody cares about
that so i just
hit it
but in the online version you'll have
access to all the code
and uh even the illustrations actually
any everything is done in the world from
language so i don't know
i don't know which one i should show but
like
like this one there's no code at all
it's because the code is actually hidden
and that's that's the code
which actually uses image bounding boxes
which detect the object so it does the
object detection like this one this one
does the
the
super resolution this one does the
translation like it's it's all uh
it's i don't think you have a lot of
fake i don't think you have any fake
illustration like it does it does the
thing
uh that it shows that's good to hear
yeah and and you can see the the code in
the online version yeah
probably the book is gonna be ready
before all right that sounds good well
i'm looking forward to it i think i'm
going to have to give this a read
because my understanding of machine
learning while it has improved over the
last year remains pretty rudimentary i
would say so this looks like a really
fantastic resource
all right thanks a lot for your time at
the end have a good one thank you
that was etienne bernard our former
machine learning lead who has written a
new book introduction to machine
learning which will be out as you just
heard hopefully in the next month or so
and i personally am looking forward to
reading it
so that'll be all for today stay tuned
for more tech talks
you